let's jump to the story here's one uh
this headline is not sensationalized
from the post-millennial Arizona Rancher
charged with murder of Mexican man was
quote hunting migrants with AK-47
prosecutors prosecutors allege that
Kelly hunted the group of men with his
gun and made numerous alterations to his
story when later spoke to law
enforcement
so you may have heard the story this guy
George Allen Kelly 73 is being charged
with murder because a guy was who was on
his property was shot they say he did it
it was an illegal immigrant with
numerous felony Crossings I guess and uh
the issue now apparently is they're
saying he hunted these migrants down to
kill them
yeah what I find strange is that Arizona
I'm pretty sure is a defensive property
State meaning you can kill someone to
defend your property
like if someone is about to cross onto
your property my understanding is that
you have a right to use a lethal Force
if they don't stop
so what's strange about this case is
that here's a guy who's on his own
property clearly someone's breaking the
law they end up shot and dead
but this guy gets arrested I'm wondering
how does that make sense
well he was trespassing right I mean
that then in the country and the land
right well and that's why I I know Vivek
ramaswamy just announced for president
and he talks about uh the difference
between immigration and illegal
immigration or people coming across the
border uh illegally and I think that's
the Crux of the matter here is is this
guy he's crossed the border illegally
and then he's crossed into somebody's
property illegally right and this guy's
defending his property he has a right to
do that as opposed to somebody who goes
through ins and goes through the process
to get the green card and does all of
that and I think that underscores what
we were just talking about about the
need to be precise in our language right
and and that's why I kind of like bevec
and him coming out and uh running for
president now you know but it is to be
precise in our language and and
understand what is happening here is why
you uh see so much confusion about
situations like this you know and the
media just seems to play into that this
guy says that uh he just fired warning
shots and there's no evidence that his
bullets hit the guy which to me sounds
like he might be telling a lie that
maybe he did go out there to shoot the
trespassers but now he's afraid that if
he says it out loud he'll go to jail for
sure so he changed his story but when
you change your story then you look like
a liar that's that's kind of what I'm
looking at the path of this situation at
the moment I think the Biden
Administration and Democrats want more
illegal immigration for a variety of
reasons one so they can increase the
population in their States they're
bringing these people in putting on
planes and flying them to swing States
and blue States and they also want the
short-term economic demand bringing in a
whole bunch of people and putting them
cities will create temporary short-term
demand followed by stagnation and
economic crisis but that short-term gain
looks good for him on paper they can use
it to get reelected and the long-term
gain is bringing in a bunch of people
who will increase the census numbers
giving them more Electoral College votes
and congressional seats so when a guy
who lives there says hey get off my
property they're coming right for me
they go this guy needs to be made we
need to make an example of him so that
people don't screw with our agenda you
take a look was it for uh McAllen Texas
is that where it's at where under the
bridge they have all the they had all
those people the bite Administration
clearly is happy with what's going on
people talk about the southern border
and Biden letting us down or failing or
whatever and it's like no he's doing
exactly what he intended to do the whole
time this is 100 by Design This is the
intent of the Democrats they have had
full authority to do something for two
years they have done nothing they did
nothing during the Obama Administration
this has been the Democrats plan for the
better part of the past 20 years to have
a cheap labor be imported into the
country that that's it's it's completely
clear I I can't take anyone that argues
against that seriously it's been going
on for 250 years dude the Southern
States imported cheap labor through the
African slave trade yeah
you can say truthfully that bringing
slaves in was quote unquote cheap labor
but
migrants coming here is not the same as
slavery migrants are coming here of
their own volition like they're walking
like
there weren't a lot of people that were
in Africa that were like you know I'm
gonna go to America and be a slave it
wasn't they weren't running out and
jumping on the slaves suddenly worse as
soon as Biden got elected or it looked
like he was going to be elected and
become president you had a mass
migration from Central America all the
way up through because they knew that
they were going to be allowed to come
through and before that you had remain
in Mexico that shirt that said please
let us in Biden or whatever right that
one yeah no they asked for it and you
know come Molly Harris comes out and
says well don't come
right and of course they're going to
listen they can even hear what she's
saying right I mean they they're not
sitting there you know on their phones
going oh well Kamala said not to go
let's go back you know it's like one of
the best memes of that year yeah look at
this the reason I have a bunch of these
the reason I brought up the African
slave trades because the numbers padding
that they're doing with the census like
what the sub I I erroneously said that
they've said all black people were worth
three-fifths of a person in the eyes of
God two nights ago that's not what it
was about it was about the north trying
to say like look we're not going to let
you pad your stats for the states with
your slaves we'll say they're worth
three-fifths of a person each legally
just so he wasn't even out there
weakened slavery and so now we've got
North the north said they're not voting
people because they're slaves the South
South said yes they are and then they
agreed on three-fifths right they were
property the South wanted to call them
property whatever but now we've got
people that are padding stats one for
one they're not legal citizens so what
do we need another three-fifths Clause
do we need to say no how about no don't
break the law right how about just
enforce the existing laws that right the
problem Sanctuary States because
existing laws they're breaking the law
is illegal the the federal government
has whether or not you agree with like
open Borders or not currently the
federal government is the organization
charged with protecting the borders and
enforcing border law and they are
completely and totally neglecting to do
that well and I think you're seeing good
signs come out of places like Texas
where you have Governor Abbott you know
saying if you're not going to do it
we're going to do it you know and we're
going to send the National Guard or send
you know the Texas Marshals down there
to help enforce but when you when you
don't have a barrier right I mean if
when you don't have something to keep
them out in places that because you
can't put eyes on every inch of the
Border all the time it's impossible so
it it the federal government is leaving
this to the states knowing that they
probably can't handle it economically
and it it absolutely is a plan it's been
working for a long long time
Sanctuary States basically means they're
not part of the Union when California
says we will not abide by Union law it's
like well then why are we why are you in
any way tied to this Union if you're not
agreement interposition let me just play
Devil's Advocate what about the
marijuana laws because like you have
what 40 States now that have said that
marijuana is legal but the federal
government says agreed you know I mean
it's it's interesting Federal
government's Got Deep problems yeah yeah
that's the idea of interposition where a
state's supposed to step in and say we
supersede your federal law which is
technically the way the country works so
in that in that instance California can
say yeah even if you're acting
xenophobic we're going to let whoever we
want then Texas should have the right to
deport
and the problem is what we're hearing
from border states is that they have no
Authority in deporting people Texas is
deporting to New York and yeah
all that's doing is putting illegal
immigrants in deeper into the country
and embedding them here yeah they're
helping Joe Biden and Democrats and
convincing their voters they're helping
their voters so you get all these
Republicans going like Yay haha it's so
funny they're doing this meanwhile
Biden's like this is awesome yeah this
is fantastic for us we're gonna we're
gonna inflate our numbers in these in
these jurisdictions and New York is
going to get more Congressional votes
it's going to get more Electoral College
votes thank you Texas thank you Florida
I do think that that there is there is a
little bit of of risk in classifying all
people that are migrants as
automatically a Democrat voter
especially considering the especially
considering the push with with LGBT uh
issues gender ideology that's not going
to fly with the Catholics coming up from
uh from South America and also you and
there's also a lot of of people from a
lot of different parts of the world now
are coming through the U.S border I've
heard people from heard about people
from Syria and from Turkey already
getting there because of the earthquake
so it's as long as that border is open
there's going to be people from all over
the world going to you know coming to
South America and then making the Trek
up through Mexico the remain in Mexico
policy will remain in whatever whatever
the safest country that you can get to
that's the correct policy if you want to
if you want to apply for Asylum that's
that's it that's the one to do I think
that we should have them personally I
think we should have a much easier
system for getting people to to
immigrate to the US I think that you
know I'm generally I like the idea of
open borders I do think there probably
has to be some kind of immigration
control but overall I think free people
should be able to move wherever they
want but the system that we have now is
not working at all when I'm thinking
about the sense this I think when you
fill out the census you don't have to
put if you're a citizen is that right is
that the way they changed it now there's
no like is there a census or is there a
citizen block and you can either say yes
I remember held out in some places well
if you don't put that you're a citizen
then your your Census count should be
worth three-fifths of a person or
nothing and Donald Trump tried getting
that on the census and they sued and the
Supreme Court said you can't do they
wanted to prevent him from forcing
people to acknowledge that they weren't
citizens I'm just saying you don't have
to acknowledge if you are you're not but
if you don't acknowledge that you are
then your censorship you wanted to put
the question on the census and they
blocked him saying you can't right
that's what I understand that because if
people had to say no then they'd just be
a target for ice well they wouldn't have
filled that out so you're saying people
who are here illegally breaking our laws
should just be allowed to keep breaking
our laws
I don't personally feel like that but
that's I think the it's a ridiculous
argument that it's like well if someone
is committing serious felonies we
shouldn't force them to tell us yes you
should the cop
ing them and arrest them and that's it
well and if you aren't a citizen of the
United States you aren't necessarily
protected by the Constitution you are
you you absolutely are prepared by the
Constitution if you're not a citizen
Constitution applies to anybody in this
country it doesn't matter if you're a
citizen or not and I'm fine with that
the issue however is if you are not a
citizen of this country and you are here
illegally or your Visa well but then you
have a right to sell not
self-incriminate you could plead the
fifth so to speak by yeah right because
right so you get the census with the
question on it and you don't fill it out
no but the idea that you can't put the
question in the census is insane and the
argument for the left was well then
people who are not citizens won't fill
it out and we'll get inaccurate readings
and it's like so the people who are here
illegally you we won't give Federal
funding to the people who aren't who are
who aren't here illegal I'm fine with
that if you're not here legally you
should not be receiving benefits in any
way California should not get a
congressional seat because of illegal
immigrants they let in and don't enforce
the laws against if the federal
government if so so this is the big
problem then this is why I feel like the
country is on the verge of blowing up
collapsing whatever you want to call it
Texas has to abide by the votes of
California when it comes to the federal
government but California is breaking
the federal rules to strengthen itself
so imagine you you got a roommate and
your your roommate is taking your stuff
and selling it and then using that money
to pay your rent or whatever and you're
like yo you can't do this you're
stealing my stuff basically well you
know I pay more rent than you so I get
more say California is breaking the
rules bringing people in then arguing
they should get more say than everybody
else
why would Texas or Florida want to be a
part of a union that allows that
I know that the national divorce
question is huge right now the only the
thing that gives me pause about this and
I understand your question because it
seems like it makes it impossible to
work with each other but I I just want
to remind everybody of what the woke
Mantra was in 2020 right it's disrupt
and dismantle right that was the whole
thing and it seems to me that the left
has done a lot of disrupting and they're
leaving it to the right to dismantle a
little bit where it's like okay we've
disrupted all this stuff aren't you
super mad at California well then we
need a national divorce because what I
keep reminding people of is that you
know first of all the more you talk
about divorce the more likely it is to
happen uh that's if you've ever been in
marriage counseling or anything like
that but the other part of it is that it
the the only thing that's keeping the
global oligarchy from from taking over
completely I believe is the Constitution
of the United States and if you have a
disillusion if you have a divorce the
Constitution is gone I mean it is in
effect gone and so then we have a
serious problem because then we've
actually brought we've brought to the
left what the left wanted in the first
place because they disrupt and we
dismantled so I would just I would I
understand the sentiment and I know it's
difficult but we've been through worse
times right but in the constitution is
basically gone as it is because red
states don't do anything Republicans
don't do anything there has been a
growing contingent of people say the
Maga movement or whatever who have been
resisting The Establishment is is
freaking out and they've been freaking
out but you take a look at Mitch
McConnell who I love this he was asked
about nordstream who could have done it
he goes well it certainly wasn't us or
something like that it's like oh yeah
okay Russia blipped their own pipeline
no sane rational person who pays
attention to politics thinks that but
this is what they do this is what they
think of you and how they present quote
unquote facts so what is what does this
mean for us if we have if we if we have
a constitution or otherwise are they
infringing on our rights to free speech
yes every single day are they infringing
on our right keeping their arms yes
incessantly they even infringed on the
third amendment with the coped lockdowns
by mandating that people who are in the
U.S armed forces could not be evicted
that violence third don't even get me
started on the fourth amendment come on
unwarranted search and seizure the mass
spying programs Fifth Amendment dude
there are people who are locked up all
the time January 6 is a great example
the list goes on and on and on but do
you think that the left is the only ones
doing that I mean that's why I'm saying
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter so
the idea now is sit back and let
California cheat and break the law and
abuse people and and let Democrats do it
nationwide and Riot and burn down
buildings or
say no and get a national divorce I
think that we have there's I think that
a national divorce is a little too
extreme and I think that I've I made an
argument on Twitter that at this point I
think uh convention Estates is the is
the only legal means to get to have to
have a divorce it says to actually
dissolve uh with that because the thing
you were talking last night about
um the Civil War the thing about the
Civil War is they didn't have the the
states to call a convention so that it
was technically illegal right this for
the states to secede because they
couldn't actually make the amendment if
you call a article 5 convention you can
actually amend the Constitution it's not
going to be easy but it's a whole lot
easier you can't be living without
electricity because we had a civil war
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time